this is Chris somebody farted in my seat
or it was from somewhere out I just nod
things brand-new do not is Mel that
cheap plastic Dan this suit just farted
bro very shocking this is Chris boys
buzz buzz Kanter sting it's rough with
people adult trick-or-treaters oh my god
[Laughter]
well what do we just say man I have no
clue is it J shop be honest with me dude
is it him
what just happened I have no idea I was
scared from the get-go though I like
that again Derek oh my god this is
scariest thing I've seen Oh Brandon dang
buzz oh that's gonna sting you adult
trick-or-treaters and I took that that's
what he looks like right this that's
what he looks like
is that Danny DeVito no what's the matte
is that Dane DeVito mask I'm not sure
[Laughter]
shaken bro
thank you the sternum Nuggets boy them
Headey pieces you got them he D pieces
you know a lot of your body warmth eyes
and your tits in here nice yeah that to
pin your ass just bro see your eyes stay
warm really avalanche wear four hats but
I'm gonna do this guy let's get out not
healthy this guy seems like a librarian
right out
how to held this is very alarming do you
see the guy he doesn't um he has that
his suit has electricity in it yeah and
then he takes that mask off and has just
a white it's just like an old man face
but then you don't have old man in here
cuz look at this here at the top I'm
going in this guy's Asian to me look at
no chest hair ooh that's a great point
let me just see his body mm-hmm is there
a shot at a waddles oh there you go ooh
that could be that's an Asian belly
mm-hmm get that see like that rare were
like very northern Asian what is that
called cat they're real white cat where
they're real yeah beige ins yeah what is
it who's the whitest Asian um I want to
see Koreans Wow because they they live
in the snow that's a Korean oh my god
they do mm-hmm oh I don't even know it
makes me feel sad that might be Trin oh
I couldn't see that being chin a little
buddy has hair oh [ __ ] that could be a
wig though Jackie Chan maybe know if I
could see his nipples I'd know what
we're dealing with there no you wouldn't
every time they get the nips give it
away dude you're better than that I
promise what do you think here Derrick
what do people say 50%
what's this question adult
trick-or-treaters I say let him rip a
lot of people don't get to live the
childhood they want to live so they
don't really get that freedom to dress
up and dude you come to my door and
you're over 30 I'm kicking in the dick
over 30 same way you got a really good
state you know yes some leeway bro hurry
up you can't come to the crib I'll
respect that actually CID bro my son you
check your ID 13 up 29 years old you
know Lynn 29 you get a nice [ __ ]
Butterfinger for your stupid face open
up that hot sac do it and we just have a
neighbor he would do actual butter for
you put his finger in butter and just
let you touch it just like you suck his
finger yeah if you wanted I just touched
it yeah yeah you can touch it with the
inside of your mouth and you want
you care what touched it that's your
culture I'm gonna say [ __ ] sting
growing up [ __ ] good I shake it baby
I like these guys and I like people
still enjoying the youth ma'am all right
you got a live for everyone
[ __ ]
[Music]